Hi, my name is Shannon Pileggi.
And here are three
reasons why you
should take What They Forgot
to Teach You About R: Project-
Oriented Workflows With Git and
GitHub workshop. Number one,
I'm really excited to co-lead
this workshop with David
for the second year in a row.
David is a solutions
engineer at Posit,
and I'm a lead data scientist
with the Prostate Cancer
Clinical Trials Consortium.
David and I work
really well together
and we learn from each other.
Our diverse perspectives really
benefit the participants
in this course.
Number two, the
spirit of the 'What They
Forgot To Teach You
About R' workshop,
are strategies to
improve the quality
of your R life via
project workflows
and version control
with Git and GitHub.
These are paradigms that you
can benefit from no matter what
stage you are in in your career.
Number three.
Lastly, the 'What They Forgot
to Teach You About R' content
is solid.
This workshop has actually
been instructed since 2018,
so the course content has
a really strong foundation
that's assessed every year to
be updated for new developments.
So I really hope you can
join us at posit::conf.
Hi, I'm David Aja.
I'm a Solutions Engineer at Posit.
Sometimes I describe
that as a role
focused on helping
data scientists get
their ideas into production.
But in practice, what that
means is that a lot of the time,
I'm focused on the
parts of working with
R that aren't about
writing R code.
But more about what it looks
like to manage it, to share it,
and to help it answer questions
for lots of different user
groups.
So the reason I think you
should take What They Forgot
To Teach You About R is I
think it helps - It's
an opportunity to help you
learn some of the software
engineering fundamentals
that aren't really
going to come up in other
kinds of R-focused programming
classes.
I know that when I started
learning R programming,
I was very much
focused on like, how
do I extract the data
from this HTML table
and not as focused on
questions like, what is it
going to look like to
work on this project
again in another year?
Or what's it going to
look like to collaborate
with this project on -
with someone else?
And I think 'What They Forgot'
is excellent venue for learning
that kind of thing.
So I hope to see you there.